l'édition édité à parlons donc si vous
le voulez bien du coronavirus non pas
pour nous arrêter à l'actualité du
moment avec ce premier mort français
mais pour nous interrogé sur les
conséquences possibles de cette épidémie
et notamment peut-être sur une forme de
fin de la mondialisation
on le sait les échanges avec la chine se
grippent la chine qui est lusine du
monde
peut-être est-ce l'occasion de re
localiser un certain nombre de
productions sur notre sol c'est en tout
cas le point de vue de bruno le maire
notre ministre de l'économie et des
finances et je pense qu'il faut tirer
les conséquences de long terme de cette
situation ça fait plusieurs mois que je
dis qu'il faut que nous réfléchissions à
renforcer la souveraineté économique
l'indépendance économique d'autres pays
en ayant la capacité de produire un
certain nombre de biens qui sont
stratégiques pour notre industrie en
france ou en europe et pas uniquement au
chine
brice couturier est ce que cette
épidémie sonnerait la fin du vaste
mouvement de mondialisation entre lequel
nous fait prendre conscience de la
dépendance dans laquelle nous sommes
tombés vis-à-vis de certains éléments de
la chaîne de valeur est l'élément
central c'est le sinn du monde c'est la
chine
maintenant ils s'imaginer qu'on va
produire des ordinateurs et des t-shirts
en france même bruno le maire doivent
pas être vraiment convaincu de ce qu'il
dit par contre oui on savait le 7 dans
le passé on fabriquait du textile si
vous voulez payer les vôtres 25 euros
pièce hook et faites-les fabriqués par
des textiles français ça sera vachement
très très bonne qualité j'en suis
certain mais vous pourrez pas vous en
achetez beaucoup dans l'année non ce qu
on va probablement assister d'une part
c'est il ya un test à l'égard de
certains gouvernements parce
qu'effectivement leur gestion de la
crise je pense à l'iran et à la chine en
particulier ont démontré la
vulnérabilité de certains systèmes
centralisés autoritaire octobre
parce que obscures en haut niveau de la
formation il ya ça et puis d'autre part
probablement oui la chaîne de valeur va
être toujours disséminés en faveur des
pays à main d'oeuvre bon marché mais ça
sera probablement des pays comme la
turquie ou l'afrique du nord où on aura
des chances de trouver des équivalents
de la chine en matière de savoir faire
mais avec à des coûts salariaux web
aussi bas que que c'est le cas en chine
de toute façon déjà en chine les coûts
salariaux était en train de monter
sérieusement puisqu'ils sont en train de
délocaliser eux-mêmes vers le vietnam le
cambodge l'indonésie et sert à
l'ethiopie ils sont en train de
descendre de même donc oui ça va mettre
à l'épreuve
1 la chaîne de valeur parce qu'on
appelle la chine à valeur c'est-à-dire
cette démondialisation
cette délocalisation de la production et
d'autre part les régimes c'est aussi
important de voir que les régimes non
démocratiques sont soumis à une épreuve
intéressante
sagan à zurich on s'est penché à
l'occasion de cette épidémie sur le
commerce extérieur par exemple entre la
france et la chine
nous leur exportons 22 milliards par an
ce qui est formidable mais on leur
apporte 50 milliards après tout c'est
une bonne nouvelle finalement cette
épidémie pour réduire notre déficit
commercial
je pense pas que ce soit une bonne
nouvelle est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les
dix villages et et d'approvisionnement
oui bien sûr mais je vais qu'on va bien
aujourd'hui que les difficultés en
matière d'approvisionnement des
médicaments et dans plein de secteurs
montrent que le commerce international
est quand même vital pour la santé
économique la santé tout court des
populations moi ça fait penser à une
petite musique on entend depuis quelques
semaines sur des gens qui fantasme sur
la fermeture des frontières en accusant
précisément la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises et la
mondialisation d'avoir favorisé
le set cette pandémie je pense que toute
cette vision toute cette cette pensée
est un peu vulgaire l'humanité la
maladie n'a pas attendu que l'humanité
vivre dans une ère hyperconnecté pour
pour la frapper pour l'accabler avec des
maladies la peste noire qui a décimé un
tiers de la population européenne au
moyen-âge et bien elle a fait des
ravages dans un monde où l'avion
n'existait pas et donc la mondialisation
n'est pas en cause
et j'irai beaucoup plus loin que ça
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand même
rappeler aujourd'hui que malgré tous les
problèmes que nous vivons
l'humanité n'a jamais été aussi en bonne
santé c'est à dire que l'espérance de
vie est au plus haut si nous ne sommes
passés de 1 milliard d'habitants à 7,7
milliards d'habitants aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas parce que nous sommes
reproduit comme des lapins
c'est parce qu'on a cessé dû crever
comme des mouches pour le dire assez
simplement et tout ça c'est aussi dû à
l'enrichissement permis par le commerce
mondial c'est le commerce mondial qui
nous a permis de nous enrichir d'avoir
une industrie pharmaceutique et médical
compétitive qui permet de mettre à
disposition des médicaments des vaccins
et ceci à une échelle massive
donc le coronavirus ne fait pas
exception à la règle que la coopération
vaut toujours prime sur sur le repli
quand il s'agit de deux d'affronter les
défis de demain et compris sur le plan
sanitaire
alors les internautes sont assez
partagés vous pouvez comme d'habitude de
vous qui nous fait l'amitié de nous
suivre sur internet
exprimez votre opinion sur twitter et
vous êtes 52 % à considérer que la crise
du corps aux navires hills pour être
tête pourrait être pardon à l'origine
d'un phénomène de démondialisation
savais pas que 48% pensent le contraire
et vous daniel bilalian qu'en pensez
vous je pense que la première chose
c'est que pour le français moyen
cette épidémie fait prendre conscience
de ce qu'est un pays comme la chine qui
n'existait pas dans le monde jusque dans
les années 1990 et qui aujourd'hui c'est
tout de même extraordinaire une épidémie
en chine mais on est en danger
l'économie monde
elle ça n'est jamais arrivé dans
n'importe quel autre pays même un pays
important ça c'est ce que le français va
comprendre
et l'autre chose ça va peut-être
l'amener à regarder dans les magasins
l'origine des vêtements ou des objets
qu'ils achètent parce qu'il suffit de
regarder de regarder leurs origines qui
est la chine le bangladesh et c'est pour
se rendre compte que l'industrie
française est en réelle difficulté est
que nous sommes nous la cause de ça même
si ne nous ne pourrions payer un peu
plus cher nos t-shirts et nos costumes
en les achetant en france ça peut
peut-être ça peut peut-être provoquer un
réflexe de citoyenneté en disant
attention arrêtons arrêtons d'acheter
dans dans ce pays cela dit ce pays est
aussi en train de se développer
les salaires vont augmenter et les bas
salaires vont partir vers d'autres
réseaux d'autres régions du monde mais
pas à ce niveau là parce que le problème
de la chine sait que c'est un milliard
d'habitants donc un milliard de
travailler dernière 4 1
voilà et qui ont besoin de qui ont
besoin de produire pour pour ce faire
pour se faire connaître
quant à elle à l'épidémie et même je
trouve que c'est encore un phénomène
aujourd'hui c'était à la propagation de
l'information et se fait une telle
vitesse que quelque chose qui aurait mis
6 mois 1 an à se faire connaître il ya
encore dix ans de ça est aujourd'hui
connue dans les dents dans les dents
dans l'est dans les quelques heures qui
suivent certains disent même est tant
mieux et invisible événement a déjà vu
dans le passé sans qu'on l'ait forcément
su parce qu'en fait je souligne amédée
voisin du sras c'est ce que le sras ça a
été un aplomb mémoire comment ça c'est
mon incident talent et pas parce que la
chine n'était pas aussi puissante
économiquement et aussi des mémoires il
avait fait sept cent quarante morts
c'est kitty à l'échelle mondiale et
quand même pas grand chose mais ça c'est
aussi le signe de la prospérité des
êtres humains c'est à dire que on a
tellement été habitué à éradiquer la
maladie lorsque survient effectivement
une
un nouveau fléau eh bien il nous
surprend il est d'autant plus violent
dans les esprits parce qu'on n'est plus
habitué à à ccc hécatombe
et c'est quelque part c'est aussi un bon
signe c'est un signe positif jacky
isabello vous êtes passionné de
politique
est ce que vous considérez que cette
épidémie qui pourrait devenir une
pandémie si effectivement être ce elle
se répand dans le monde entier est une
espèce de de parabole du lepénisme c'est
à dire il faut fermer les frontières il
faut relocaliser
c'était un des arguments de campagne du
rassemblement national les appelle ça le
logo réalisme alors à beaune red bull
le phénomène est mineur mais il existe
de manière non pas ostentatoire mais
bien visible couche imiter qui est quand
même assez connu à relocaliser toute une
partie de sa production alors non pas le
thé mais tout un tas d'autres les
éléments salomon a fait pareil le coq
sportif donc il ya un phénomène parce
que le consommateur veut de plus en plus
de petites quantités très personnalisé
est beaucoup plus vite donc de ce point
de vue là de ne pas systématiquement
considérer la chine comme le l'atelier
du monde c'est quelque chose qui laisse
une trace dans les chiffres
après quand on regarde dans la chaîne de
valeur auparavant la chine était le pays
qui fabriquait des choses à basse valeur
ajoutée ce n'est plus le cas donc dans
la chaîne de valeur elle prend de plus
en plus de place pour compléter les
choses très brillante qui ont été dits
non moi je pense que c'est intéressant
cette cette épidémie parce que si on
reprend un peu la pensée de jean tirole
qui a beaucoup écrit comme vous le savez
sur les sur les les biens communs de ce
qu'il ya une nouvelle déco n'est pas la
nôtre prix nobel d'économie c'est
intéressant parce que
dans cette société assez instable où on
se rend compte de plus en plus que cette
instabilité a des impacts sur
l'environnement que l'air c'est un bien
commun c'est important que l'os est un
bien commun c'est important et bien que
la santé et le système de santé publique
c'est important pour une économie qui
fonctionne bien est ce qu'on peut voir
là c'est que derrière toute la
propagande chinoise et bien leur système
de santé publique ne fonctionne
absolument pas donc ce qui est en train
de paralyser l'économie mondiale ça
n'est pas le coronavirus c'est
l'incapacité du système de santé public
chinois à endiguer ce phénomène là parce
que ça c'est déjà pas si vous reprenez
l'alien ils ont du mal aussi nom depuis
quelques jours ils ont du mal ils ont du
mal papa à la proportion des chinois si
jamais vous demander au premier ministre
de bloquer 50 ou 60 millions personnes
comme viennent de le faire les chinois
déjà un juridiquement ça sera très
compliqué on pourrait pas le faire mais
rappelez vous qu'il y avait une très
très bonne culture économique mon cher
guillaume quand il eut fukushima les
chaînes de valeur de tout un tas du sinn
un peu partout dans le monde ont été
considérablement bloqué de la même
de la même manière ce cette incapacité à
organiser leur santé publique est
quelque chose qui démontre que le
capitalisme bienfaiteur pour tout le
monde
il doit tous prendre en compte et donc
quand nous ont dit on ne doit pas
opposer capitalisme et système social eh
bien on doit la répéter aujourd'hui
parce que vous le voyez même si on est
un peu paniqué eh bien je pense que l'
agence de santé publique française à
l'ensemble des dispositifs pour arriver
à bloquer la propagation de ce virus en
france je sais que j'ai j'ai assez dit
qu'il fallait pas se cacher la tête sous
la couverture mais moi je le verrais
plutôt que de cette façon là et d'un
point de vue des chinois c'est une
catastrophe vous connaissez ce pays pour
ceux qui y sont allés
il n'ya pas d'hygiène il n'y a pas de
médecine de ville
derrière lors lors deux hôpitaux qu'ils
ont construit vous avez des gens qui
crèvent dans des dents des pauvres
hôpitaux qui ne porte ce nom que parce
qu'on n'a pas d'autre mot et ce truc là
porte un coup fatal à l'économie
mondialisée
mais l'économie mondialisée en tout cas
ne reculera pas sage
ceci dit
mauvaise intéressant de voir observer
dans quel pays émergents un éventuel
vaccin ou éventuelle si c'est aux états
unis que ça se passe dans des régimes
libéraux ça apportera aussi un coût pour
ici qui voudrait que les systèmes
autoritaires soient nécessairement les
plus efficaces et les plus productifs
pour lutter aussi contre ce genre de
maladie ou est ce couturier les idées
qu'on appelle protectionnistes sont à la
mode dans nombreux pays
donald trump a même été largement élu là
dessus est ce que vous pensez que ça
peut les faire progresser dans l'opinion
française ou est ce que c'est une le
coronavirus cela va-t-il selon vous un
tournant ou une parenthèse une
parenthèse je vois vraiment pas comment
le processus de mondialisation pourrait
reculer
il est dans ce que je crois profondément
c'est qu'il va y avoir des zones civiles
il est très probable qu'elle alors ils
ont des 10 prochaines ou des 20
prochaines années il ya une zone
chinoise où les standards ou les modes
de vie où les intérêts chinois prédomine
et une autre qui soit occidentale
occidentalo 10 ans américaines ou
européennes dans lequel les standards
européens les modes de vie les valeurs
etc et les intérêts donc probablement
plutôt une régionalisation de la
mondialisation une bifurcation 2 ou 1 3
ou en 4 zones différentes mais l'idée
qu'on puisse fermer les frontières et
fabriqué jeunes ou même des ordinateurs
des voitures des t-shirts et des et des
médicaments c'est totalement absurde on
n'imagine pas les belges faire une chose
pareille
tout va dépendre de la durée de cette
épidémie
c'est ça qui va être déterminant si elle
est résolue dans les dents dans le
premier trimestre ça sera un épisode et
on en parlera plus et tout dépendra mon
avis de la durée c'est la durée qui peut
remettre en cause le régime chinois et
l'importance de la chine non parce qu
avant de remettre une usine en août en
france je pense que quelqu'un va
peut-être attendre au moins un trimestre
ou un semestre avant de se dire puisque
j'ai des problèmes d'acheminement de la
chine je vais me remettre à travailler
dans mon pays et puis et puis le
raisonnement qui consiste à dire on va
tout mettre en france pour éviter de
s'exposer aux risques mondiaux est
complètement d'ebita dire que demain
s'il ya un problème en france c'est une
maladie en france et que tout s'arrête
en france que fait-on si on n'a plus la
possibilité d'importer non mais veut
dire le libre échange c'est aussi la
capacité de diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement c'est ce qui fait
qu'on à lutter contre la famine c'est ce
qui fait qu'un un pays qui a des
pénuries
parce qu'il ya des problèmes climatiques
bien peu se tourner vers un exportateur
c'est comme ça qu'on a éradiqué le la
pénurie ces dernières décennies c'est
grâce à la diversification des sources
d'approvisionnement grâce au libre
échange
le principe est quand même et quand même
intéressant c'est vrai que pendant ces
vingt dernières années on avait
systématiser la mondialisation
aujourd'hui si on veut installer
des process de production agricole qui
soit un peu plus aux normes que nous
vantons on va le faire mieux chez nous
que si on faisait ne serait ce que par
exemple en espagne on va pas entamer le
débat sur le bio la différence entre ici
que ça nous permettent de redécouvrir
je vais pas faire mon gardien de base
mais qu'on peut avoir des avantages
comparatifs en france pour certains
types de production est privilégiée
locales comme certains le font encore
une fois et même dans le domaine du
textile
on voit très régulièrement dans le nord
que sur des produits à forte valeur
ajoutée
on relocalise mais que ça nous permet de
diversifier ce processus oui mais par
contre dans les chiffres vous le savez
guillaume sait absolument pas vrai si
les chiffres de la mondialisation
diminue c'est parce que on fait encore
plus d'économies sur les composants de
vence à mondialiser est donc dans la
masse des chiffres qui sont produits on
a l'impression que ça baisse
mais sur le volume savoure sa baisse à
seulement pas en volume en la regza
compost aux internautes
d'abord gadget qui nous rappelle que le
corona virus a fait deux ou trois morts
en france même un seul cherchait qu'à
notre connaissance alors que la grippe
quant à elles tuent des centaines de
français chaque année citoyen payeur
considère lui que nous allons enfin nous
apercevoir de notre dépendance vis-à-vis
de la chine
philippe est favorable à relocaliser ce
qui est essentiel sur le plan
stratégique et enfin cette remarque de
claudius 15 qui nous rappelle que la
chine produit aussi la plupart des
principes actifs de nos médicaments et
enfin cette dernière réaction
elle nous vient de siffler qui estime
que la mondialisation est un choix
politique et pas une obligation
parlons si vous le voulez bien